Who knew three months ago that the left Parness
the name left Parness would be almost a household
name to followers of American politics.
But here we are on the first day of Donald
Trump's impeachment trial in the Senate, and
not only his left Parness in the news daily,
the white house is desperate to prevent left
Parness from testifying at Donald Trump's
impeachment trial.
So let me catch you up quickly if you're one
of the privileged few that does not know who
love Parness is.
I envy you.
Donald Trump hired Rudy, Rudy Giuliani as
his personal lawyer, Rudy in getting ambassador
Maria Bonovitch out of the way.
Those are Rudy's words, not mine.
Hired two henchmen, Lev Parness and Igor Fruman.
Love Parness has chosen to cooperate and after
being indicted and has the goods on Trump
and everybody around him, including, we've
now learned that love Parness coordinated
physical surveillance for Rudy Giuliani of
ambassador Maria Bonovitch in Ukraine, which
is utterly and completely insane.
Democrats want left Parness to testify.
Makes sense.
I already said yesterday, Parness is accused
of multiple crimes.
He's not a clean guy.
The left should not put too many of our eggs
in the Lev Parness basket, but he does seem
to have the goods on Trump.
He does seem to have evidence that would be
damaging to Trump in a Senate impeachment
trial.
So the Trump legal team is scrambling to prevent
left Parness from spilling the goods.
The wall street journal reports, quote white
house officials would, uh, also block any
attempt to include testimony from Lev Parness.
In the Senate trial, the people said, mr Parness
and associate a Rudy Giuliani, the president's
personal attorney who was working on his behalf
in Ukraine, offered new allegations last week
that have inflamed the debate about whether
senators should call witnesses in the president's
trial, which opens Tuesday.
Mitch McConnell seems more than willing to
play ball and to help other Republicans also
seemingly interested in preventing left partners
from testifying.
And of course, when you look at the law, there
is no real legally defensible reason to block
Lev Parness from testifying.
He's not a government employee.
There's no issue of executive privilege.
Republicans constantly complain, Hey, we don't
have firsthand information and evidence in
this case.
Lev Parness has it.
He could provide more of it.
They should want him to testify by their own
standard of wanting firsthand information,
but of course they don't because they're all
wrapped up with love Parness and they know
that Parness his testimony would be absolutely
destructive to Donald Trump.
Yesterday, we showed you how Lev Parness knows
everybody around Trump, pictures with Trump,
pictures with Mike Pence, pictures with Eric
Trump, Don jr, Ivanka Trump, Jared Kushner,
Kellyanne Conway, and on and on and on.
They simultaneously demand a type of evidence
that love partners can provide but want to
prevent left Parness from testifying and providing
exactly that type of evidence, firsthand evidence
which they claim to want love.
Parness is a material witness if there was
ever one.
And then of course when you zoom out, you
get to a realization that has been underlying
this entire thing the whole time.
If Trump is innocent, why would you be against
people testifying?
Innocent people want to prove their innocence.
Love Parness is Rudy Giuliani's guys, certainly
Parness isn't some plant by the left to take
down Trump, right?
I mean, if Trump hires the best people and
Trump hired Rudy and Rudy hired love partners,
it must be because deep down Donald Trump
knows that he is guilty of exactly what he's
been accused of and likely much more, which
love partners can testify to Trump and his
lawyers don't want evidence at trial, period.
That's all that this is any evidence they
can block, they want to block.
So what happens with love partners, I don't
know.
We'll find out soon.
It's not just left.
The white house is also considering classifying
the testimony of former national security
advisor John Bolton to try to conceal it.
We will also be covering that in more detail
as the story develops probably later this
week.
Today.
By the way, I just, just as a heads up, we'll
be live streaming.
Today's first day of the Senate impeachment
trial.
I want to warn people, we are very unlikely
to get to any of the real trial.
My guesses either until like Saturday, they're
doing Saturday sessions or even next week
because the first several days are going to
be a combination of guidelines, setting up
the plan for the trial and attempts at obstruction
and dismissal of the entire trial by Republicans.
So we're going to start coverage today.
If you're going to be watching today, just
a warning, it's going to be a lot of grand
standing today and it could be a while until
the real trial as we believe it.
Uh, witnesses, evidence, testimony, et cetera.
It's going to be awhile until that starts,
but we will be covering it.
We will also have a poll question about the
trial on our Instagram page.
Follow us on Instagram at David Pakman show
and follow me on Instagram at David dot.
Pacman.
A lot of kooky hate mail that I've been getting
can ramping up.
I've been posting to my Instagram page at
David dot. [inaudible] quick break right back
out to the